- [Kelly] All right, we are back.
And earlier this year I
celebrated my 40th birthday,
and here on the show,
(audience cheering)
they went all out.
I'm very excited.
I was surprised though,
with a Mariachi band, margaritas,
even a giant queso fountain,
which, come on, that's heaven.
And I'm not the only one who's gotten
to party in style on their birthday.
From fine wine, to terrifying
clowns, to giant elephants.
I've heard some amazing stories here
on this stage so take a look.
You have a big birthday coming up, 30.
- I do.
- That's exciting.
(audience cheering)
- The big 3-0.
- 30, 30, 30, y'all.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Kelly] Your husband, Chris Pratt,
he had a birthday,
right? A recent birthday.
- Oh, yeah, last week.
- What'd you get him?
- I got him piggies.
'Cause I was told they would
stay small, they did not.
- You had kind of an
LA birthday this year.
- I was like, "Guess what guys,"
"you're doing cryo for my birthday!"
- [Machine Gun Kelly] Dave
Chappelle flew us on his jet
to just chill with him for a night.
We landed and he was like,
"Ooh, forgot we gotta go to"
"my mom's 81st birthday party."
(audience laughing)
- Did you turn 40 this year?
- I did turn 40.
- Are you 1979?
- Yes, sir.
- This is something you
can enjoy this year,
I know you've had an incredible year.
Or you can save it 'til you're 50.
- Holy cow.
- And for me this is one of
the great wines of the world.
- This is 1979, this is the--
That'll bring a tear to your eye, no joke.
- Thank you, man.
- That's for real.
- This is a real--
- This is one of the most
rare wines of the world.
(audience clapping)
- Is this photo from one
of your birthday parties?
'Cause this is, you look terrified.
- [Taylor Lautner] See, I don't even
remember where that's from but, yeah,
clearly you can see it
in my eyes. I'm not--
- I will say, Flip Flop the
clown does look scary as hell.
Like, it's like--
(both laughing)
- I mean, who likes clowns?
- Well, and that one particularly looks
like he might wear your skin.
- Flip Flop is--
- Yeah. (laughs) Like, he might, yeah.
He looks scary. Like, he
looks kind of scary, yeah.
- He's a little sketchy.
I do not trust him.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- During the movie you
celebrated your birthday with,
is it the mordida? Mordida?
- Yeah.
- Is that how you say it? Okay, okay.
- [Salma Hayek] There is a
tradition that we have in Mexico
that, when the cake
comes, you make a wish,
you blow the candle, and
then somebody behind you
whacks you on the head,
- What?
- And puts your face inside of the cake.
- No!
- Very normal in Mexico.
And Angie, she just
came to bring me a gift.
And when everybody started,
(claps) "Mor-di-da! Mor-"
She's like, "What's happening?"
And I said, "Oh, this is tradition,
and you're sitting next
to me, so you get to put,
She goes, "I'm not gonna do
that! Are you guys kidding me?"
I said, "No, no, no, no.
Really, it's a tradition."
"Somebody whacks you in
the head inside of a cake?"
- It's a weird tradition.
- And I said, "Yeah,
just do it, it's okay."
(mimicking Angelina Jolie) "I can't!"
"Just do it!"
And all of a sudden
she's like, very girly,
and all of a sudden she goes like, BWOOM!
(Kelly laughing)
She was worse than Valentina!
And I'm afraid of my daughter
when it comes to the mordida,
but you know what?
She'll have her birthday coming.
(audience clapping)
(Kelly laughs)
- Gonna play the mordida.
- We'll do the mordida to Angie.
- You're gonna be sitting' right there.
- Yeah.
- Love that.
- For my 40th birthday, my friends
got me a message from Ken bone.
Ken bone was the guy, and
I became obsessed with him
for some reason, who in--
- Who is Ken Bone?
- I'm gonna, well, that's
what I'm about to tell you.
So, Ken Bone was the guy,
in like the 2016 election time
there was a debate. And
this one very special man
from the audience was
wearing this tight sweater,
you guys remember this?
He had like this sweater,
and he just was, he just completely--
- Oh!
- [Josh Gad] Ken Bone!
That's Ken Bone. Thank you to your crew
for showing you Ken Bone.
(Kelly laughs)
So, so I became obsessed.
So they knew I was obsessed,
and they got him to
deliver a message for my birthday,
and it was just, that was so wonderful.
- I love that you have
met (bursts into laughter)
so many amazing people.
- Like, Steven Spielberg,
just like, every pop star, and I'm like,
Ken Bone.
- Ken Bone.
- Yeah.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Ken Bone.
- That's amazing.
- Barbra Streisand? Yes, I've met her.
We're talking about Ken Bone.
- Ken Bone? (Kelly cheering)
- Yeah.
- (laughs) That's amazing.
(audience clapping)
- [Howie Mandel] It was her birthday, and
I wanted to surprise my
wife. My wife loves animals.
Any kind of animal.
- Me too.
- So, I, an elephant.
I rented an elephant.
And I had it brought to the house.
There's the elephant.
And there's my wife.
(audience laughing)
So the next day, the gardener came,
he comes around the corner,
the yard has these holes
that are 4 feet deep,
the sprinklers are broken,
5 palm trees are laying
all over the place,
and there's a pile of,
and the guy walks in and he goes,
"Mr. Mandel, what is this?"
And I go, "It was my wife's birthday."